selecciona la función definida a trozos
cuya gráfica se muestra abajo bueno
supongo debe decir a la derecha lo que
pasa es que copie y pegue la imagen
entonces tenemos esta función definida a
trozos que es continua no está definida
para x igual a menos 2 o menor y
empezando en x mayor a 2 negativo
empieza a ser definida y es continua
hasta llegar al punto x igual a 2
después tenemos aquí otra vez una
discontinuidad y empieza a estar otra
vez definida aquí abajo luego es
continua hasta llegar a x igual a 6
después otra vez está indefinida la
función aquí como puedes ver después de
x igual a 6 así que bueno pensemos en
cuál de estas funciones describe a la
función de la gráfica aparece de ser que
esto es una función radical trasladada
entonces raíz cuadrada de de x se
miraría algo así se miraría esta es
bueno ese es el color no se ve aquí está
un color que si se ve entonces esta es
la función raíz cuadrada
de x se mira algo así y esto parece ser
raíz cuadrada de x trasladada a la
izquierda
entonces parece raíz cuadrada de x + 2
podemos verificar por ejemplo cuando x
es igual a menos 2 tenemos menos 2 más 2
eso es raíz cuadrada de 0 lo cual es
igual a 0 y no está definida ahí pero
vemos que si la función continuará si
estaría definida ahí intentémoslo con
más números entonces cuando x es igual a
menos 1 que tenemos menos uno más 2 es
igual a 1 raíz cuadrada de 1 es igual a
1 entonces ahí está ahora x igualados 2
más 2 es igual a 4 raíz cuadrada de 4 es
igual a 2 positivo entonces raíz
cuadrada de x + 2 parece ser un buen
candidato para esta función cierto y
bueno no lo voy a llamar de ninguna
forma pero puede ser la función ph geo
efe entonces bueno la función sobre este
primer intervalo parece que es raíz
cuadrada
de x + 2 para para menos 2 menor que x
nuestra definida en menos 2 pero pero
siempre y cuando x sea mayor que menos 2
y x sea menor o igual que 2 bueno
funciona para esta primera parte de la
función luego vemos que da un salto
hacia abajo esta función parece parece
ser que es x al cubo entonces la función
x cúbica se mira se mira algo así veamos
entonces se ve algo así menos 2 al cubo
es igual a menos 8 ahí está entonces la
función x cúbica se ve algo así en 2 al
cubo es igual a 8 entonces bueno sé que
es como que estoy repitiendo mucho pero
x al cubo se mira algo así y la la que
tenemos aquí parece ser que es x cúbica
pero trasladada a cuatro unidades
entonces x menos 4 al cubo parece ser un
buen candidato para esta función
verificar x iguala a 444 al cubo es
igual a 0 cuando x es igual a 66 -4 es
igual a 2 al cubo igual a 8 y cuando x
es igual a 22 menos cuatro igual a menos
2 al cubo también es 8 entonces podemos
decir que esta parte de las funciones x
menos 4 al cubo ahora para qué
x entre qué números veamos ok veamos
esta para x tenemos x menos 4 al cubo
para x x mayor que 2 cierto entonces o
lo que es lo mismo lo que es lo mismo 2
menor que x y está definida hasta x
igual a 6 como podemos ver entonces pero
claro no mayor que 6 entonces para x
menor o igual que 6 así que bueno cuál
de estas opciones es la correcta
veamos aquí tenemos raíz cuadrada de x +
2 para menos 2 menor que x y x menor o
igual que 2
x 4 al cubo para 2 menor que x menor o
igual que 6 entonces hdx está correcta